hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's 4 I literally just got back
from VidCon I drove back up about an
hour ago and I'm ready to play some more
because this game came out a little bit
of an inopportune time now I have to get
back in the swing of things because I've
totally forgotten how to play and I've
totally forgotten the horrors that await
me okay so as we all know I was being a
little impatient the last time and I
wasn't giving it what it was properly do
get out of here already
right so alright so as we all well know
we need to be more patient on the
breathing you get out of here you get
out of your bonbon you're not welcome
here anymore I don't like all the
sprinting I totally forgot oh I hear
some stomping around over there whoa
what was that that was definitely
breathing
I just got to be more careful about it
just got to be more careful about it
that's all I got to do that's all I got
to do that's all I ever got to do yeah
you got out here oh boy oh boy yeah
because everyone was telling me because
I was actually recording this before vid
King Khan and this came out on the day
that was supposed to go down and so it
was like bad timing because I was
unfortunately supposed to be able to oh
man
and I was supposed to be able to well I
mean whoa whoa breathing in my ear
someone doesn't need to do that okay
alright okay we're okay we're okay yeah
here okay foxy hasn't even gone the
closet yet that wasn't breathing but
okay yep that's breathing god that
Stephie steps stop stepping all over the
place yeah things to do
Oh hate waiting like that okay we're
okay we're actually doing pretty good
surprisingly okay so far so good
so far so good so this came out as a
complete surprise to everybody because
no one knew it was gonna be released as
early and I had no idea and I thought
everyone was down for VidCon ninh and
oddly enough you know talking to
everybody down there who normally plays
this game and they were like oh man
hello they were like holy crap I can't
believe the game care out already I'm
over here VidCon okay okay okay
ah geez oh man something about this
thing the full moments of anticipation I
don't like it okay okay
four am Jesus I'm kind of wondering like
why nothing's been happening yet oh man
he's not usually at the end of the
hallway after I do that
I don't know if the clanking means the
chicas in the kitchen
and she's like busy I just wanna bake
you a cupcake no no no cupcakes please
Shh
hi foxy don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] you just
stay stay stay stay
good boy good boy down doggy oh man
you're still quite active oh god I gotta
move okay
I gotta move gotta move gotta move gotta
move gotta move gotta move I know the
screamy kids are getting screamy I know
that's great because okay okay okay foxy
foxy foxy okay
probably bad I'm just gonna close it
pause ooh cute he's so cute I wish you'd
go to hell enjoy so cute Oh oh no was
that breathing I thought I heard
breathing there oh okay
yes yes yes I'm good I'm good at games
I'm good oh my heart is going like a
million miles an hour after that all
right one day and build a party oh boy
the party that's so low should why am I
here why am I here please let me out
who locked me in here
[Music]
what the hell happened please yes I'm in
the animatronic storage room like the
spare parts room please
this poor kid please let me out he's so
sad no wonder he has nightmares
that was it oh that was it okay now I
gotta have fun with plushtrap great
gotcha
yes I might be able to beat right I
might be able to roll right into the
fifth night if I can do this right if I
can do it right it'll be good I'm gonna
die I'm gonna die but let's do this come
on to our head start great great great
great great what is that what was that
that was a new noise okay weird little
weird okay what the hell is happening
okay that was golden freddie was I
supposed to shut the door was I supposed
to shut the door
probably holy crap okay let me try that
again
damn it always my two hour head start I
always lose it
hi okay I'm probably supposed to shut
the door immediately if I see golden
Freddy what is he doing here why is he
here alright oh I wasn't ready for that
I was not ready Oh piss one more dry
what we're talking about come on
maybe I was supposed to hold the
flashlight on him the only thing I could
assume Jesus this is gonna be a [ __ ]
what does I do
it's like different it's the footsteps
sound different that's the thing the
footsteps fat sound very different hi
everybody
editing markiplier here I noticed when I
was editing this video that everytime
golden freddy popped up it coincided
with me ahead when there were no teddy
bears on it so it might be a trigger for
bad gameplay by checking the bed when
you didn't need to this might be true it
might not be but there didn't seem to be
a way to beat him and I haven't played
this still but this is a markiplier
parole check for free so have fun good
luck don't die here hi so before I go I
just want to say thank you everybody who
stopped by and said hi to me on VidCon
thank you for everyone who attended the
signing thank you for everyone who went
to the panels thank you for everyone who
showed me love it was great fun you know
I went to some parties but in the end I
do mean waiting a bunch of other people
we ended up just going to a hotel room
and playing cards against humanity'
instead of going to parties which
honestly was a lot more fun than the
party's worth so thank you everybody so
much for watching thank you for
supporting me through this if you've got
tips to how to beat going Freddy let me
know in the comments below thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]
[Music]